La guerra de Ucrania todavía está lejos de
acabar. Pero desde luego ha entrado en una
nueva fase. Mientras Rusia ha reorganizado sus
fuerzas para intensificar su ofensiva en el este,
lo cierto es que las tropas rusas se han retirado
de Kiev. Aún así la capital de Ucrania sigue
siendo bombardeada y muchos pensaréis que es
pronto para hablar de la reconstrucción del país.
Pero después de 2 meses de guerra es evidente
que el conflicto no se ha desarrollado tal y
como figuraba en los planes iníciales del
Kremlin. El ejército ruso no ha sido capaz
de controlar buena parte de Ucrania. Todo
indica que el oeste y el centro del país no
van a caer en manos de Putin. Por este motivo ya
hay gente que está pensando en el día después de
la guerra. Ahí tenéis las palabras del comisario
europeo de Presupuesto, Johannes Hahn. Mirad.
Ucrania necesita un nuevo Plan Marshall tras
la invasión rusa, apunta la Comisión Europea
Estamos ante la mayor devastación en Europa desde
la Segunda Guerra Mundial. Por eso cobra sentido
hablar de lo que sería una especie de nuevo
plan Marshall. Hablamos por supuesto de una
inversión multimillonaria. Pero también de
una gran oportunidad para Occidente. Porque
atraer al bloque de las democracias liberales
a un país como Ucrania, el segundo más grande
del continente europeo, sería meter un gol por
toda la escuadra de la portería del Kremlin.
Ucrania goza de suelos muy fértiles y tiene más
de 40 millones de habitantes. Una población bien
formada y que no está tan envejecida. Merece la
pena ayudar a Ucrania a salir adelante y hacer
posible que muchos inversores privados inviertan
en Ucrania. En este vídeo te vamos a contar cuánto
costará reconstruir Ucrania. Por eso la pregunta
es: ¿De qué cifras estamos hablando? ¿De dónde
podría salir todo ese dinero para reconstruir
Ucrania? ¿Qué lecciones podemos sacar del
antiguo plan Marshall? Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos
a responder a estas preguntas. Pero antes vamos a
ver un poco de Historia.
EL PLAN
MARSHALL
Todo el mundo piensa que Estados Unidos puso
en marcha el plan Marshall nada más acabar la
Segunda Guerra Mundial. Sin embargo amigos, no
fue así. La guerra en Europa acabó en mayo del
45 y el Plan Marshall no arrancó hasta que lo
aprobó el presidente estadounidense Harry Truman
a comienzos de 1948. Lo cierto es que en 1945 los
Aliados estuvieron a punto de cometer los mismos
errores que al final de la Primera Guerra Mundial.
El Tratado de Versalles impuso entonces a Alemania
unas condiciones tan duras que con el tiempo
propiciaron el ascenso del nazismo al poder.
En Estados Unidos hubo un hombre que se dio
cuenta. Hablamos del general George Marshall,
en aquel momento secretario de
Estado de la Administración Truman.
Marshall creía que la recuperación económica de
Europa sería buenísima para Estados Unidos. La
guerra había provocado un esfuerzo industrial
extraordinario. Pero también había llevado al
país al pleno empleo. Mantenerlo en tiempos de
paz era todo un reto. Para ello sus empresas
necesitaban seguir exportando. Ahora bien, con los
países europeos completamente devastados después
de 6 años de conflicto, ¿quién iba a comprar
sus productos? Subvencionando su recuperación,
Estados Unidos ganaba un mercado
en el que vender sus productos.
Aquí está una de las claves: el
90% del Plan Marshall fueron ayudas
a fondo perdido. Pero esperad un momento,
porque esto no era precisamente un ejercicio
de solidaridad de Estados Unidos. El Tío
Sam repartía dólares pero fundamentalmente
para que se compraran sus productos. En su
primer año el 60% del Plan Marshall se gastó
en comida. Poco a poco se fue invirtiendo
más en maquinaria, en volver a poner en
marcha la industria y en completar las tareas de
reconstrucción. Al final se estima que un 30% de
los fondos del Plan Marshall se dedicaron a
materias primas y productos semifacturados,
otro 30% en alimentos y fertilizantes, un 20% en
maquinaria y vehículos y un 15% en combustibles.
El Plan Marshall también cumplió con un
cometido político. Estaba perfectamente
encuadrado en la Doctrina Truman. Esta política
del presidente Truman establecía que Estados
Unidos debía brindar apoyo económico
y militar a cualquier país del mundo
para contener la expansión del comunismo o las
fuerzas soviéticas. Gracias al Plan Marshall,
16 países que recibieron la ayuda estadounidense
salieron adelante, su situación política
se estabilizó y no cayeron en el comunismo.
Ahora bien, muchos pensaréis: pero a ver Fonseca,
siempre que hay ayudas y dinero en abundancia
se corre el riesgo de invertirlo mal. En
Washington también pensaban lo mismo. Así que
crearon la ECA, una agencia autónoma que vigilaría
el proceso antes de soltar la pasta. Cada país
podría decidir cómo aprovechar los fondos del Plan
Marshall pero primero tenía que hablar con la ECA.
Lo importante es que
en los 4 años que se aplicó el Plan
Marshall, Europa vivió el periodo de
máximo crecimiento económico de su historia.
La producción industrial se incrementó un
35%. La agrícola sobrepasó ampliamente los
niveles de antes de la guerra. Y Europa tuvo
por delante dos décadas de un crecimiento sin
precedentes que impulsó la inversión privada.
Y ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando
todos en este momento. Todo esto está
muy bien pero... ¿Cuánto costó?
El Plan Marshall costó 13.000
millones de dólares. 13.000 dólares de la época.
Estamos hablando del 2% del PIB estadounidense
de entonces para reconstruir toda Europa. La
gran cuestión es si ahora estaríamos dispuestos
a hacer semejante esfuerzo por un país como
Ucrania. No podemos obviar que Reino Unido,
Francia… al fin y al cabo eran países con muchos
lazos con Estados Unidos. Pero es que con Ucrania
estamos hablando de un país que hasta hace 4
días nos importaba menos que la vida privada
de Will Smith antes de la gran bofetada. Así
que, ¿estamos dispuestos en Occidente a pagar
la reconstrucción de Ucrania? ¿De cuántos ceros
estamos hablando? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA
FACTURA UCRANIANA
Vamos a decirlo claro: Ucrania ya era el
país más pobre del mundo antes de la guerra ¿Por
qué eran tan pobres? Tenemos varios vídeos donde
lo explicamos. Pero, si las cosas ya estaban
mal en enero de 2022, en Mayo de este mismo
año están mucho peor. El país está devastado.
Y cierto es que, hasta que no termine la guerra,
es inútil hacer valoraciones de daños porque
estos seguirán aumentando. Pero hay quién ya
se atreve a hacer algunas estimaciones. Atentos
al presidente del Banco Mundial, David Malpass:
El Banco Mundial ha completado una primera
evaluación del daño físico. Habla del coste
en términos de edificios e infraestructura, el
mínimo daño que se puede evaluar, y lo cifra
en aproximadamente 60.000 millones de dólares y
no incluye los crecientes costes económicos que
está teniendo para la economía de Ucrania.
Este cálculo es ligeramente inferior al que
indicó la Escuela de Economía de Kiev, que
hablaba de unos 68.000 millones de dólares.
De estas cifras, la mitad corresponde
a la factura que supondría restaurar
las infraestructuras dañadas. Hablamos de
28.000 millones de dólares en daños a las
carreteras. A eso habría que sumarle los puentes,
puertos e instalaciones ferroviarias afectadas.
Luego están los 20.000 millones de daños en
edificios de viviendas entre los que directamente
han sido destruidos y los que están a punto
de caerse. Otros daños no alcanzan cifras tan
elevadas pero tienen mucho valor para la futura
calidad de vida de los ucranianos. Reconstruir
200 instalaciones de atención médica costará
otros 2.000 millones. Y para reparar los centros
educativos afectados también se necesitarán
unos cuantos cientos de millones de dólares.
Pero esperad un momento, porque tal y como
indicaba el presidente del Banco Mundial,
esto solo son los daños físicos que
podemos cuantificar. Según el primer
ministro de Ucrania, Denys Shmyhal,
la factura real de la reconstrucción
será bastante más elevada.
Nuestro análisis previo ha
demostrado que las pérdidas directas
e indirectas a causa de la guerra
ascienden a más de 560.000 millones de dólares
estadounidenses. Y si no detenemos esta guerra
juntos, las pérdidas aumentarán considerablemente.
Estas cifras serían un poco más elevadas que
las aportadas por un equipo del Centro de
Investigación de Política Económica, con
sede en Londres. Estos ofrecen una horquilla muy
amplia que oscila entre los 200.000 y los 500.000
millones de dólares. El Plan Marshall supuso para
Estados Unidos un esfuerzo equivalente al 2% de
su PIB. Esto equivaldría actualmente a 450.000
millones de dólares. La pregunta es: ¿De verdad
está Occidente dispuesto a pagar esta factura? ¿De
verdad merece la pena? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
TABULA RASA
En el año 1991, Ucrania y Polonia eran dos
países muy parecidos. Ambos acababan de salir del
comunismo, ambos tenían alrededor de 40 millones
de habitantes y ambos tenían un PIB per capita
similar. A partir de ahí, cualquier comparación
resulta odiosa. Atentos a esta gráfica.
¡Ya lo veis! Ucrania tan solo ha cosechado
más éxitos que Polonia si únicamente nos
ceñimos a su historial en el Festival de
Eurovisión. Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué han
hecho en Polonia que no han hecho en Ucrania?
La diferencia es que en Polonia el poder quedó
en manos de Lech Walesa. que no le tembló el
pulso para desmontar el régimen comunista y
hacer una apuesta decidida por la democracia
y la liberalización de la economía. Justo lo
contrario que los primeros líderes de la Ucrania
independiente, herederos del Partido Comunista
Soviético. Desde entonces las diferencias
entre ambos países fueron abismales. En 1995
Polonia ya había privatizado la mayor parte
de su economía. Ucrania ni siquiera había
liberalizado la compraventa del suelo agrícola.
Vamos, que estaban en preescolar de capitalismo.
En 2004, Polonia ya estaba lista para entrar en la
Unión Europea. Los datos hablan por sí solos: los
polacos son 3 veces más ricos que los ucranianos.
La pregunta es ¿Puede Ucrania convertirse en una
nueva Polonia? ¡Por supuesto! Pero para
eso tiene que acercarse más a Europa y
menos a Rusia. No sólo en relaciones
comerciales sino en sistema político.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la legislación
laboral ucraniana se remonta a los años 70,
cuando todavía formaban parte de la Unión
Soviética. Los dos principales bancos del país
son estatales. La liberalización de la compraventa
de suelo agrícola se aprobó hace sólo dos años.
Y la hiper corrupción se ha mantenido en todas
las esferas del estado hasta antes de la guerra.
Sin embargo, la guerra no sólo está destruyendo
las infrastructuras del país. También se está
llevando por delante toda esa maraña de
intereses creados y corrupción. Y hay una
cosa donde Zelensky ya ha acertado de pleno:
apostarlo todo por entrar en la Unión Europea.
Vamos a ser claros: si Ucrania consigue cumplir
con todos los requisitos para entrar en Europa,
significa que va en la buena dirección
¡Pero no sólo eso! También supondría una
fuente de ingresos muy importante. Volvamos
al caso de Polonia: durante sus primeros 15
años como miembro de la Unión Europea, Polonia
recibió ni más ni menos que 160.000 millones de
euros en fondos comunitarios.
Ahora bien: como hemos visto,
Ucrania necesita mucho más que eso. Antes
hemos hablado de alrededor de 500.000
millones de dólares ¿De dónde puede salir
el resto? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA HISTORIA LA ESCRIBEN LOS VENCEDORES
Ucrania ya ha creado un Fondo para la
Reconstrucción del país. Está estructurado
en 4 fondos diferentes. Uno enfocado a
reparar las infraestructuras destruidas;
otro a atender las obligaciones
financieras del país y pagar sus deudas;
el tercero a apoyar a las pymes para restablecer
la normalidad en el sector privado; y el cuarto
dedicado a modernizar el país. Ucrania tiene
un sector IT muy interesante, con profesionales
bien formados. Incluso antes de la guerra,
Zelensky ya quería apostar por esto. Atentos.
Queremos transformar Ucrania en un país de
startups. Esperamos que la participación de
la tecnología en el PIB crezca del 4 al 10% para
2025, hasta los 16.500 millones de dólares, lo que
nos convertirá en el hub tecnológico más grande de
Europa. Volodymir Zelensky, Presidente de Ucrania
Por supuesto que esto es de antes de la
guerra. Pero la intención de Zelensky está
clara. Y Ucrania tiene el talento para poder
reconstruir rápidamente su sector IT. Además,
vamos a ser claros: los sueldos ucranianos pueden
ser muy competitivos para empresas occidentales.
Dicho de otra forma: mano de obra barata
para las startups europeas y Estadounidenses.
Ahora bien: el estados Ucraniano sigue necesitando
aún más dinero ¿Quién puede ponerlo? Desde
Kiev lo tienen claro: RUSIA.
Sí, habéis oído bien: Rusia.
Desde Kiev están presionando para hacerse
con los activos congelados al Estado ruso
y a sus oligarcas. Por de pronto esto
presenta dos problemas muy evidentes.
El primero es que los rusos llevan años
preparándose para una situación así y, en contra
de lo que pueda parecer, no se están incautando
tantos bienes. Las autoridades suizas han actuado
sobre unos 8.000 millones de dólares. A priori
no está mal, pero sabe a poco cuando la patronal
indica que los bancos suizos poseen más de 200.000
millones de dólares de riqueza rusa. En España los
notarios reclaman al Gobierno nuevas medidas
legales ya que consideran que de momento no
pueden actuar contra los oligarcas rusos. Y lo de
Portugal… bueno, lo de Portugal se comenta solo:
https://www.swissinfo.ch/spa/ucrania-guerra_portugal-solo-congela-una-cuenta-rusa-que-sumaba-242-euros/47445238
Portugal solo congela una
cuenta rusa que sumaba 242 euros
Portugal only freezes a Russian
account that added 242 euros
El segundo problema es que estamos ante medidas
que violan la propiedad privada. Está claro
que Rusia debe pagar por el daño infringido en
Ucrania. Pero hasta qué punto es justo que paguen
por ello los oligarcas. ¿Deben Europa y Estados
Unidos violar sus principios? Es para pensárselo,
porque se está sentando un precedente que nunca se
sabe donde puede acabar. Y como pasó en Versalles,
no sería la primera vez que imponer
condiciones muy duras para la paz
acaba desencadenando un conflicto aún mayor.
En cualquier caso, ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros. ¿Creéis que Europa debería apostar
por Ucrania y financiar su reconstrucción?
¿O pensáis que habría que obligar a Rusia y
a sus oligarcas a pagar por todo los daños
que está causando la invasión? Podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios. Si os ha
gustado este vídeo, darle a LIKE y nos vemos
en el próximo. ¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!